Bien, il est 10 heures 12 et je commence
à tourner la vidéo qui sort à 11h
Parce que je ne me suis pas réveillé.
Comme un ... (gros blaireau).
Eh ben oui c'est marqué dessus.
Salut la team mentalo !
J'ai remarqué que dans les commentaires, vous me demandiez souvent
comment vous pouviez faire pour vous
entraîner à la détection de signaux non verbaux
C'est bien l'objet de cette
vidéo du dimanche.
Et concernant le concours de vendredi je fais le tirage au sort là, dans quelques minutes et
je mettrai le nom des gagnants (parce que je veux faire gagner plusieurs personnes) dans la description.
Alors j'ai bien réfléchi et je trouve ça hyper légitime de me demander comment vous pouvez vous entrainer
Alors évidemment vous pouvez observer les gens permanence
mais c'est compliqué pour les premières phases d'apprentissage
Et c'est vrai que j'ai un petit peu oublié ça puisque j'ai passé ce cap.
La solution, c'était de créer un jeu
vous allez proposez un jeu à faire à vos amis, à votre famille, peu importe, même aujourd'hui.
Et sous prétexte de ce jeu qui n'est pas prétexte pour les bluffer mais pour vous entrainer
Vous allez pouvoir peut-être les bluffer
mais assurément pouvoir prendre le temps d'observer dans une circonstance
qui est plus naturelle
Plus naturelle que de regarder fixement quelqu ' un qui vous parle comme ça, sans aucune raison
vous allez proposer à quelqu'un le jeu de l'intrus. C'est à dire :
Vous mettez une personne en face de vous et vous lui demandez de répondre à des questions très simples
Comme : Quel est ton âge?, Quel est ton prénom?
et ensuite deux à trois questions pour
stimuler sa recherche visuelle ou auditive
si tu as déjà eu un animal, quelle était la
couleur de cet animal
Est ce que tu peux me fredoner ta musique préférée
décris moi les vêtements que t'avait hier
attention à cette question qui peut faire
très perverse aussi
Et vous alles forcément voir tous ces mouvements oculaires
Je vous invite d'ailleurs à regarder les vidéos que j'avais faite sur la détection de mensonges sur la PNL...
Je vous mets tout ça dans la description. Les liens directs ce sera plus rapide
vous avez en tout cas pouvoir voir
comment fonctionnent ses yeux
Et vous lui proposez un autre jeu directement après :
C'est de vous raconter deux choses qui sont vraies et une chose qui est fausse.
Deux petites histoires très courtes qui lui sont vraiment véritablement arrivées
et une autre phrase qui est inventée ou qui ne lui appartient pas mais qui est inventée de toutes pièces c'est beaucoup mieux.
Il décide dans quel ordre il vous les raconte
Et à la fin vous serez capable de dire quelle était la phrase intrus
parce que forcément vous allez regardé tous les signes du mensonge qu'on a pu voir dans les vidéos
les vidéos et en plus de ça vous avez
assez peu de chance de vous rater
puisque vous allez vous aussi vous
concentrer sur les mouvements oculaires
et vous allez voir que quand il va raconter son mensonge les yeux ne bougerons quasi pas
le peu qu' ils bougeront ce sera vers le côté créatif
mais ils ne bougeront quasiment
pas puisqu'il n'y a pas de recherche mémorielle
à faire et c'est très très
flagrant et comme c'est un signe qui
est très facile à repérer dans ce jeu
vous avez tout le temps en même temps
de vous concentrer surtout les autres
conseils que je donnais dans les vidéos
pour regarder de quelle manière ils
apparaissent sur la personne.
Petit Bonus :  et ça c'est un plus en fait
Petit Bonus qui va bien vous pouvez lui demander de
faire la même chose les yeux fermés, les
paupières fermées
parce qu'on voit beaucoup mieux les mouvements occulaires
quand les paupières sont closes
On voit encore mieux les yeux bouger. Là, je vous ai proposé que la personne, elle raconte
deux histoires vraies une histoire fausse
mais ça peut être trois histoires vraies une histoire fausse, quatre vraies une fausse,
voir même trois vraies et deux fausses vous pouvez  après corser la difficulté pour mieux
encore vous entraîner.
L'intérêt en plus de cet entraînement, c'est que vous pouvez le faire toujours avec la même personne
c'est pas gênant du tout.
voilà c'est presque un TP aujourd'hui c'est travaux pratiques
mais j'espère que ça va répondre à
une question
que vous m'avez beaucoup beaucoup posé.
En parlant de beaucoup beaucoup vous avez été
plus de 2300 à participer au concours que j' avait lancé vendredi
je fais le tirage au sort avec le site là de trucs aléatoires
Que vous m'aviez montré il y a des mois de cela
Et je mets le résultat des gagnants
directement dans la description
j'avais dit que je ferai gagner un livre
Et puis en fait je vais en faire gagner plusieurs
Donc si vous voyez votre nom
en dessous sachez que mardi,
je commanderai directement les livres qui arriverons directement chez vous.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au
bout j'espère que ça va vous servir et que ça vous a plu.
Et si c'est le cas
n'oubliez pas de faire un petit pouce en l' air.
Là c'est très important les pouces en
l'air parce que si vous en mettez
beaucoup sur cette vidéo,je referai un espèce de truc de travaux pratiques.
En fait je me rends
compte que ce que je vous apprends,
vous arrivez pas toujours à voir comment
l'appliquer. Donc si ça vous dit
qu'on en fasse d'autres dans le même état
d'esprit,
(bruitage chelou) Vous bombardez et (bruitage chelou)
est un bruitage complètement *rire* chelou. Passez un excellent dimanche
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à
la chaine avant de partir
puisque le mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez-vous de demain à 17h mon pote.
Ciao!